فى منزل أنثى السنجاب دق دق الباب
دق دق دق
من بالباب
أنا تيته يا أولاد ومعي كعكة عيد ميلاد افتحوا يا احلى احفاد
صوتك خشن انت الثعلب اذهب اذهب يا كذاب مادامت ماما بالخارج لن ندخل ابدا اغراب
فى منزل أنثى السنجاب دق دق الباب
دق دق دق
من بالباب
أنا جدو ومعي هدايا حلوى رائعة للغاية انتم فى امن وحماية
صوتك خشن انت الثعلب اذهب اذهب يا كذاب مادامت ماما بالخارج لن ندخل ابدا اغراب
فى منزل أنثى السنجاب دق دق الباب
دق  دق دق
من بالباب
انا بياع الألعاب هي مجانا يا أصحاب افتحولي هذا الباب
صوتك خشن انت الثعلب اذهب اذهب يا كذاب مادامت ماما بالخارج لن ندخل ابدا اغراب
فى منزل أنثى السنجاب دق دق الباب
دق  دق دق
من بالباب
أنا عمو جئت لكى نخرج نقضى وقتا ممتع مبهج ونشاهد فى السيرك مهرج
يا عمو ما أحلى اللعب هل تسمح نصطحب الكلب
هاو هاو هاو
لا لا لا ما هذا الرعب لا .لا.تفتحوا لى الباب
هاهاها....... يا كذاب انت الثعلب هيا اذهب ما دامت ماما بالخارج لا لن نفتح هذا الباب